what happens if you go out there and you
tell your jokes no one laughs nothing
happens you get paid the same you're not
gonna die do you ever want to do
something great in your life you're
gonna have to realize your failures are
gonna have it embracive and figure out
how to overcome Dave Chappelle is the
baddest person to touch a microphone
that's alive right now
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe in your potential and I want
to see that thing that you've got inside
you explode out into the world to have a
big impact for you your family and the
world so to help you on your journey
today we're gonna learn from Comedy
Central's number one stand-up comedian
of all time Dave Chappelle and my take
on his top 10 rules of success rule
number four is my personal favorite and
I'd love to know which one you guys like
the best and as always guys as you're
watching if you hear something that
really really resonates with you please
leave it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy
do you remember how Dave first
discovered comedy yes I do yes I do dr.
Yvonne Seon is Dave Chappelle's mother
she's a minister and a college professor
I think the moment he decided to be a
comedian was a day that he had to decide
whether not to sign up for the second
week of basketball camp and he called
home he said mom you said there guys
here who are bigger than I am run faster
jump higher
everybody was better than me but I had
them all cracking up so I figured Livie
let me tweak my vision let's look at my
old high school just in encourage the
kids and I told them straight up I said
if y'all wanna make it out of this
ghetto you're gonna have to stop blaming
the white people for your problems
you're gonna have to focus and you were
gonna have to learn how to rap or play
basketball or something you're trapped
[ __ ] you are trapped either do that'll
sell crack rocks that's the only way
I've seen it work when I was maybe 19 I
opened for Aretha Franklin at Radio City
wow yeah
looking back on it I'm sure she didn't
choose me herself
but it was great it was it was bad I was
gonna go back as a headliner oh my god
but 19 and liked it when I was 19 I had
a paper rod but did we're looking back
on it were you prepared at 19 for that
kind of a gig yeah it was 15 minutes I
had about 30 minutes then mm-hmm you
know I was prepared enough yeah I mean
was I as good as a wreath of Franklin no
no well my job is just to get people
used to looking at the stage I'm the
opening act
yeah it mattered to me if I did good but
nobody really cared is this you know a
big gig like this they they have a
rehearsal do they have a walkthrough
they have like a sound checks and that
kind of thing I don't know
I imagine no big sound check you know
you could either go what send a guy
right
wouldn't you were 19 did you go for a
sound check well I skipped it which was
a terrible mistake that was a mistake
that was a terrible mistake I skip the
sound check
and nobody could hear me for the first
three minutes but you know you know what
it is Dave you've been a stand-up for
many years and and you know you probably
get that question when people tell my
god you're a comedian well what happens
if you go out there and you tell your
jokes and no one laughs nothing happens
you get paid the same you're not gonna
die and a bad happen so I keep it all in
perspective where key and Peele became
the comedians to watch I think there was
a speculation that Dave doesn't like key
and Peele or Dave thinks okay no I'm a
fan of this show you know when I did
Chappelle's Show
there were certain conventions of the
show that the network resisted and I
fought the network very hard so that
those conventions could come to fruition
we are looking for a Clayton Bigsby look
now further fella you found me the first
episode I do that black white
supremacist kitchen it's like that's ten
minutes long it should be five minutes
now why should it be five minutes long
like these types of converters and I
fought very hard so when I watch can
appeal and I see they're doing the
format that I created and at the end of
the show us is created by an appeal that
hurts my feelings
whenever I hear likely fled to South a
become like me and I walked out I walked
by John way but I wasn't walking away
from money I was walking away from the
perfect storm of food I told you I was
an insane asylum they told you maybe he
smokes crap
they told you everything but the truth
may be corporate America with human
beings like their products in
investments maybe brings into the world
and says this 50 million dollars as pile
of money it's all for you and when you
try to grab it it just goes right on top
I don't want to be co-opted or severity
I don't want to be my own worst enemy or
be used against myself Dave Chappelle is
the baddest person to touch a microphone
that's alive right now I mean I will say
it and I will I will stand by it
me and Chris Rock we're at a show we're
about to leave no money and Chris Rock
we were um we're at the Comedy Cellar
and it says this night is it's one of
the best nights of comedy like just by
accident I go I just want to work
although I'm cool
I just want to work on some jokes as I'm
going onstage Chris Rock walks in the
door I go what up Chris what you know
you gonna you know yeah I was I was
gonna work out I thought I might to go
up now I'm gonna come down I'm come down
i watch save it some funny stuff like
that's that's what comedians are
supposed to do we're supposed to watch
and hey I got something funny for you
because I sense of humor is all
different I come off Chris giving me
notes where laughing I go you going up
you say yeah i'ma go up now it's alright
I'll do the same I sit in the back Chris
goes you weren't cemetary gets all hey
look this is funny this is funny as hell
what do you say this and oh good good we
just shoot Chappelle comes in yeah what
up god hey y'all go up already yeah we
just went up you own up yeah I real
watch man Chris sit in the back dave was
up probably for 20 minutes there was a
moment where me and Chris looked at
ourselves and the jokes that we just had
we were going over at the same time
we bald like this this it was like yo we
stink like God our level of thinking is
horrible Chappelle is just different man
30 years how has the crowd changed like
now it seems like everyone's offended by
everything
it's like how that's a very good point
people are sensitive now all the sudden
or oversensitive maybe there's a lag
grainy quote that grating that created
the Simpsons there's this famous quote
he says the world is filled with people
who are dying to be offended by
something what the world has now is an
Internet for those people to voice their
offense so they can make something out
of nothing they can spend your work and
make something that's beautiful look
like it's ugly and vice versus like I
say my specialist is the age of spin so
so everyone is becoming a spin doctor so
it's now granted comedians make mistakes
it's part of the job you know
and some mistakes are easily forgivable
some wildly more extreme but the idea is
that we want a society where we are late
allowed to make mistakes were able to
voice our opinions and change our pants
so I just I just let it rip I'm not
afraid of the audience you know I think
the vast majority of people that come
out they get it they know what it is and
there's always some people within cities
intent they try to derail you bring you
down
I will just spin the ball but that's you
know as you get as you go all the
business you guys it's toughen up and
just hope that your numbers don't come
up I'm sure my next special have
somebody man
you tell jokes from everything from race
to politics do you worry about crossing
the line or is there a line that you
won't cross although I can see that in
recent years that seat has been occupied
by by Mexicans and I dare say Arabs and
we the black Americans would like to
thank you both for your sacrifice
reinstructive economies would the line
moves it changes but I think a lot of
expression Congress added it has to do
with intent and your intent is to make
people laugh to reconcile paradox I'm
like just openly sometimes we're just
open the event I think that when you get
to a certain altitude there's more
scrutiny over the things you say because
the platform is so powerful one of the
things we found interesting because we
came and saw you on what will be done in
Toronto oh yeah yeah we came and saw you
in Toronto ahead and I was at this show
that was a dope-ass show the first thing
they do is they take your phones that's
the news shows yeah here so you can't
have a phone and they locked it up
that's the first time did you come up
with that I started working with this
company yonder and it maybe save my
career because basically you know
comedians we need the element of
surprise and you also need a sense of
security that you can make a mistake you
know a lot of comedians been hitting the
wall bill maher wreck the other weekend
Kathy you know wreck this part of effing
right part of the genre though like you
you don't want comedians to not take
chances in this new world of precision
of social precision where everyone's
talking and living like politicians not
I'm not ready for anything you got I'm
good to say what to say
mm-hmm and sometimes I'll be wrong and
many times I'll be right but you have to
have the freedom to do it so I a lot of
people's phones up
because it empowers me to do a better
show and to be more honest you're not
just precise see what needs to be
changed or at least nobody exploiting
Felicia
[Music]
then when you dismount from Network
television your father's also dying then
right yeah he died not too long after
that so you know in the hills and
valleys of everyone's life this sounds
like you're pretty dark Valley huh
this was a beginning of a terrible
decline yeah it was around this time
that Chapelle retreated to a sanctuary
in Ohio he left behind the network TV
deals the cliche movie roles the heavy
partying left it behind to spend more
time with his wife and family and to
take a good hard look at himself I was
looking at myself for the first time and
I didn't like everything that I saw you
know well you got to do that in your
life you know if you ever want to do
something great in your life you're
gonna have to realize your failures are
gonna have it embrace it and figure out
how to overcome I like your city it's
beautiful tolerant place I didn't see
much I have this in my friend call there
was like a having fun - Frisco hell yeah
seen the sights no you wanna go see
Alcatraz so what kinda diggin is right
man what's a visit a prison for it
prison being on all visit
I don't deal with jails don't deal with
jails and I don't deal with police my
house got robbed and y'all I didn't even
call the police
I wanted to but I couldn't
my crib is too nice that is too nice but
it's too nice for me he's still here
taste Johnson apparently this black guy
broke in and hung up pictures of his
family every way never seen anything
like don't deal with the man I had to
bail a friend of mine out of jail one
time you know that was horrible I was
scared I had to walk right into the
belly of the beast
I tried to look as non-threatening as
possible hi I'm here to bail out my
buddy
oh okay well while you're here you do
fit a description you'll walk this way
we can process you spit in those damn
descriptions all the police I'll tell
you I blame
Stowe's sketch artist
they keep drawing the same
and all who is this generic man we all
look like
I don't know what they say when it says
you only only be in their room liking
you get a look just see the guy that
tried to rob you
yes yes I did he's about six feet tall
I'd say six feet tall
yes he had his hat on backwards too good
that's good stuff was on backwards yes
it was black okay big lips big nose came
out say no more sir drawn from memory
now let me get my stencil I think we can
trace this guy and same same time they
get on the radios calling all cars
calling all cars be able to look out for
a black male between 4 7 & 6 8 pounds
he's wearing like geez get this man
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because fou hoon asked
me to if there's something you'd like me
to cover in a future top ten check out
the link in the description and go and
cast your vote I'd also love to know
what did you learn from this video what
lesson really hit home the hardest what
are you going to immediately apply
somehow to your life or to your business
leave it down the comments below I'm
really curious to find out I also want
to give a quick shout out to Devon Trish
Devon thank you so much for picking up a
cup of my book your one word posting to
your Instagram account
I really really appreciate the support
and I'm so glad that you enjoyed the
book thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever you're
one where it is much love I'll see you
soon
who was the first guy that blew you off
stage don't think ever get blown off Wow
I felt some heat in DC tear that at that
time you'd already left but Teddy carbon
and Teddy carpenter was one of those oh
yeah Teddy carbons want us do is they
would like like like really bring it to
you
I took some else I'll tell you got me
remember Chris Thomas yeah yeah
destroyed only done stand-up like four
times and they were like we're gonna put
you know Chris Towers by this time must
be doing stand-up like but 42 years man
and they and they were like Dave we're
gonna put Chris up next and then again
see literally goes you can go home I'm
staying
I bought it was the worst I dry mouth
bomb you ever give me bombs or bandage
my thirsty I think I think part of us
because you were like a young comic you
didn't have the experience of know how
to transfer that energy from one well
that's exactly what was the lack of
experience so cut to like years ladies
when we were all doing like Def Jam tour
def Comedy Jam tours and we were Madison
Square Garden the show was Chris Thomas
Chris Tucker and they made me clothes
man I'm Murph that that was my karate
kid' tournament night was a while he was
making movies he was still creating and
pitching TV sitcoms of starring himself
which is when the Fox Network calls I
flew out there for a meeting if you can
imagine I was the only black person in a
room and they basically told me that the
will pick up the show but we want more
white characters on it so no other
reason and they thought that it would
give the show the more universal appeal
and so I quit then in there in
California you quit we quit
you walked out lean and longer the room
yes did you accuse them of racism and
lutely it was it was racist good I don't
think these people sit around a house
and kind of call black people [ __ ]
and all this kind of thing but the idea
that unless I have white people around
me on my show that it's unwatchable or
doesn't have a universal appeal it's
racist you know then they don't let me
put black people on friends or they
don't make them put black people on
Seinfeld but all the sudden I get in the
room and it's like where's all the white
people my mother and my grandmother were
freaked out you know I was the first
person in my family not to go to college
that had not been a slave right
so I was really breaking from tradition
and it was like a graduation lunch we
were having and they had my dad come and
talk to me and my dad takes me outside
and it's like listen and this is some
advice applies to all you acting
students he says the big actor is a
lonely life everybody wants to make it
and you might not make it and I said my
dad well well that depends on what
making it is there it was smart smartass
kid yeah it spins on what making it is
there he says what do you mean I said
well you're a teacher I said if I
couldn't make a teacher salary doing
comedy I think that's better than being
a teacher and he started laughing you
say if you keep that attitude I think
you should go he said but name your
price in the beginning if it ever gets
more expensive than the price your name
get out of it thus the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon pay believe nation if you
want to know what the most important one
word is for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk
Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and Howard
Schultz I have a very special secret
video for you check the description for
details
[Music]